نبقى في لبنان حيث قال الامين العام لحزب
الله اللبناني حسن نصر الله ان الامريكيين
ابلغوا المسؤولين اللبنانيين بان اسرائيل
ستشن حربا على لبنان اذا لم يوقف حزب الله
عملياته العسكريه جنوب البلاد واضاف نصر
الله في كلمه له انه اذا لم تكن جبهه
لبنان مؤثره لما احتاج الامريكيون الى كل
هذه الضغوط مؤكدا ان حزب الله سيقاتل بلا
اسقف وبلا حدود على حد
تعبيره الامريكي الذي يحاول ان يقدم نفسه
خائفا على لبنان او حريصا على لبنان عليه
ان يخاف على اداته في المنطقه على قاعدته
العسكريه في
اسرائيل وهو انما يضغط على لبنان من اجل
اسرائيل من اجل ايقاف هذه الجبهه من اجل
تعطيل هذه الجبهه لو كانت هذه الجبهه غير
مؤثره وغير فاعله لماذا يحتاج الا
كل هذا التهديد والتهويل والضغوط نحن منذ
99 يوما نحن جاهزون
الحرب لا نخافها لا نخشاها لن نتردد
فيها وسنقل عليها وكما قلت سنقاتل فيها
بلا اسقف وبلا ضوابط وبلا حدود